talked a lot lately about the challenges
facing home buyers
one thing we've mentioned the cost of
lumber is skyrocketing
in fact one new home builder woodside
homes has fallen victim to
lumber theft costing thousands of
dollars aside from the rising costs of
raw goods
sheer demand is making things even
tougher madison kimbrough
explains new home inventory has been
huge for us this year a lack of
inventory tied together with near record
demand
means getting a hold of a new home site
in some cases is like winning the
lottery literally the builders are
overwhelmed with the demand that they're
experiencing
so instead of creating these long lists
they are now doing a lottery system
which is the fairest way that they've
established
they can distribute the few listings
that they do have coming available
people are turning to new construction
because the resale market just isn't
what it used to be
as homeowners are staying put many
people are nervous because if they do
sell their homes
they're nervous about purchasing another
home in this market they don't want to
end up in a situation where they don't
have a home to live in and with new
construction homes they're hard to build
without materials
we had about ten thousand dollars worth
of lumber stolen from this job site
actually
from this location where we're standing
right now mohader is the general
superintendent for builder woodside
homes and explains that because of
lumber's high demand
it's a common material to steal that
combined with the pandemic effect
it's making things tough right when
kovitz started a lot of the mills shut
down
and so that created a strain on what we
have so the demand of homes is high
we have a limited supply as mills are
opening up
they have certain protocols for covid
which we are now seeing that
that is reducing their their production
as of now hader says no suspects have
been caught but they've asked new
homeowners in the development
to keep a sharp eye out madison
kimbrough 8 news now